welcome ghosts and ghouls to October
top-five 2018 I'm Walter Binet dziak
I'm Heather Roose and I'm my anna-wade
every week this month will feature
Halloween themed countdown starting
today with an old favorite last year I
had the opportunity to cover the best
and worst episodes of goosebumps but
there's so much more I want to talk
about with this show the monsters and
villains and goosebumps are a lot of
people's favorite part we didn't always
need a great antagonist to make for a
great episode but when most fans think
back to seeing this show as a kid or
reading the books the first things that
come to mind are probably those monsters
that the kids and the stories had to
face off against in some form or fashion
it's the biggest part of this brand
identity and their escape from oral
Stein's stories was the entire premise
of the 2015 movie when I cover the best
episodes last year I included some of
the show's most well known bad guys to
branch out a little more and highlight
some of the perhaps lesser-known
monsters I won't be repeating episodes
so if you're wondering where slappy the
horrors or the Haunted mask are they
won't be included here if you'd like to
hear my thoughts on them and more take a
look back at the best episodes video now
let's get into some of the most heinous
bloodthirsty baddies the masked mutant
an attack of the mutant they went all
out with this episode and even got Adam
West to play a comic-book hero
Oh Batman No Oh cat man no he played the
galloping gazelle oh well is he at least
heroic that's it
I'm out of here wait you're on your own
it was a strange appearance but
would you expect anything less from the
bright Knight himself attack of the
mutant follows a comic book obsessed boy
named skipper weird named Chris
for hero who slowly realizes his
favorite villain has entered the real
world the masked mutant begins stalking
skipper as the boy discovers the mutants
hideout shielded by an invisibility
cloak as skipper himself begins to
appear in the comics he's reading he
finds out that the villains intentions
are more sinister than he could have
ever imagined
this was a very different episode of
goosebumps which is why I liked it so
much it's still strange and eerie but
balances a tone of mystery and
playfulness that not a lot of the other
episodes accomplished this well it just
has a very unique feeling to it
including advertising itself on the side
of a bus there's something unsettling
about the masked mutant he's not scary
per se like I don't remember being
afraid of him as a kid but there's just
something off about him that sets him
apart from a lot of the more standard
monsters this show gave us over its run
[Music]
he has a great voice and laughs the
mutant almost reminds me of a less
creepy version of the ghastly grin er
from are you afraid of the dark not
quite on that level but there are some
similarities
he's memorable he's odd he stands out
the masked mutant is definitely one of
the best goosebumps monsters
what are you gonna do destroy number
four the pumpkin heads in attack of the
jack-o'-lanterns if Jack pumpkin had
from Return to Oz freaked you out then
these are the goosebumps monsters for
you drew is delighted when her old
friends Shane and Shana come back into
town to visit for Halloween they plan to
go trick-or-treating with Drew's friend
Walker while local bullies Tabitha and
Lee tag along
however on Halloween night drew Walker
Tabitha and Lee are approached by large
pumpkin headed beings who escort them to
a secret neighborhood where they can
trick-or-treat the candy portions are
generous but eventually the kids start
to recognize this neighborhood is more
trick than treat spoilers for this
episode in case you want to check it out
these are some quality goosebumps
monsters their insistence that the kids
keep trick-or-treating goes from funny
to threatening
too much of a good thing is a worthwhile
lesson learned here they throw a triple
twist at the end of the episode
revealing the pumpkin heads to actually
be Shane and Shana then revealed they're
actually aliens then reveal that they
eat humans they leave on their spaceship
with a warning for the kids not to get
too fat from the candy or they'll come
back to consume them next year that's a
lot to take in
did I mention the pumpkin heads also
spitfire number three the ghost from
piano lessons can be murdered this
episode actually had a few contenders
for best monster jerry and his parents
just moved into a new house that was
apparently vacant for many years things
take a strange turn when an old piano
left in the basement starts playing on
its own Jerry even starts seeing a ghost
sitting at the piano but after prompting
from his father he starts taking piano
lessons at the nearby shriek school soon
Jerry realizes that the strange
happenings in his basement and this new
piano school are connected in a very
supernatural way this ghost isn't
exactly the main antagonist of the
episode but she is pretty creepy this
character plays on the basic fear of the
unknown and unexplained it's very subtle
at first and built up well as Jerry
keeps hearing the piano play the same
tune over and over when he sees the
ghost it's pretty freaky and not too
overdone are you afraid of the dark
mainstay Aaron tagger makes an
appearance as the equally creepy dr.
shreek while the character mr. toggle
adds another strange presence to an
already spooky episode I think the ghost
was presented the best though and
whenever she showed up and made for an
unpleasant scene
[Music]
number two the werewolf in the werewolf
of fever swamp this is probably the most
well known monster on our list it's one
of those that springs to mind when you
mention goosebumps Grady and his sister
Emily just moved to the swamps of
Florida with their scientist parents the
siblings heavily disliked their new
surroundings as they both feel isolated
and alone plus strange howls at night
dead animals mean local Hermits and
strange occurrences start to pile up all
these things combined have Grady asked
himself is there a werewolf and fever
swamp this two-parter takes the
slow-burn approach as we don't see the
wolf until well into the second episode
the costumes imperfections are well
hidden by clever and effective lighting
that punctuate a very well produced
installment of the show a nice twist
towards the end of the story helps this
episode distinguish itself as a classic
when used correctly werewolves are an
old-fashioned monster type that can
still be impactful on a solid narrative
goosebumps utilized this paradigm well
[Music]
I'm trying not to repeat the same
villains I already spoke about last year
was a challenge even still there were a
few monsters that just missed out on the
list so here they are as honorable
mentions
[Music]
[Applause]
and the number one best goosebumps
monster is the Scarecrow's in Scarecrow
walks at midnight brought to life by a
book of dark magic these scarecrows are
pure terror
if only they had a brain okay did I miss
the Wizard of Oz reference memo today oh
yeah Jodie and Mark are visiting their
grandparents farm but something just
doesn't seem quite right things are
slightly different and everyone working
at the farm are clearly keeping
something from the visitors the
scarecrows in the cornfield catch the
attention of mark and Jodie for their
gruesome appearance and every once in a
while it almost seems like they move the
scarecrows are the perfect mix of
mystery intimidation and fright
I love how they switch from people in
costumes to real scarecrows from shot to
shot at some points it really makes the
characters question their sanity how
they creep about in the darkness lit
only by lightning strikes and a few
shots sets a really chilling tone I like
the other characters in this episode -
there's a good variance on types here
that works towards the story's benefit
it's not the best episode of the show
but it without a doubt features some of
the best monsters goosebumps has ever
produced
there's much more I want to say about
these honorable mentions so this calls
for an episode of the countdown continue
see how these monsters ranked as I go
into more detail about them in a new
video on my personal channel out now
I'll also be reviewing 2015's goosebumps
movie very soon as well as its sequel
when that debuts in theaters next week
we want to hear what you guys think
what's your favorite goosebumps monster
what do you want to see us cover next on
the show leave a comment and let us know
to keep in touch you could like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
and you can find me on Facebook Twitter
Instagram or subscribe to my animated
movie review series multiplex 10 and you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter I stream on Wednesday nights
I'll catch you right back here next week
with the worst goosebumps monsters on a
brand-new episode of October top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]